All right.
Hello and welcome, everyone.
It's ActInfLab Livestream number 46.0
and it's June 10th, 2022.
Welcome to the ActInfLab, everyone.
We're a participatory online lab
that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied
active inference.
You can find us at the links
here on the slide.
This is a recorded
and an archived livestream,
so please provide us with feedback
so we can improve our work.
All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome
and we'll be following
video etiquette for livestreams.
Head over to ActiveInference (dot) org
if you want
to learn more about livestreams
at the lab or other projects
that are ongoing.
All right.
We are here in the first discussion,
the .04 background
and context in stream number 46.0.
We are learning and discussing the paper
"Active inference
models do not contradict folk psychology"
by Ryan Smith,
Maxwell Ramstead, and Alex Kiefer.
And video, just like all
the videos are, is an introduction
and contextualize her and an appetizer
for some of these ideas.
It's not a review or a final word.
We're going to say hi
and give introductions.
Then we'll be covering the roadmap
and abstract claims and aims,
and then we'll head through
some of the core sections of the paper
and just get some of the key
arguments down.
And during the dot one, in the dot
two, in the coming two weeks,
we'll have open space
for asking a lot of questions
for those who want to participate,
live and ask questions as well.
So on we go.
We'll start
just by
introducing ourself as much
or as little as we'd like.
And if we want to, mentioning
something that we're excited
about in the paper, like what brought us
to want to contribute to this zero
and all start.
I'm Daniel,
I'm a researcher in California
and I think the title says
it all, though
there's still more to add,
and it speaks to many of the hottest
and brightest debates
in active inference,
which is
the rubber hitting the road with mind,
brain and body
and psychology
and previous and different conceptions
all pass it to Dean.
I standing on Dana up here in Calgary,
I think.
Well, a couple of things.
First of all,
one of the first act of interest
that I was on
was a paper that Ryan had written.
And so
I was kind of impressed with that paper.
And I knew that
if I sort of invested some time
in this one,
that's that
I would become
previous.
And the primary
premise was looking at
active inference
from the decisioning and
at the movement standpoint,
sort of seeing that
looked at from a higher order
and the lower order type of processing.
And that when I,
I got into the paper
and started looking at the mind, world
and world
mind piece and, and seeing where the,
the potential connectors were between
sort of coming in to it,
not necessarily
knowing that
there would be different things
that active inference,
much like
I didn't realize
it was an extended active imprints
teller redox actually constance paper
that was kind of helpful
and I'll pass it to Jake.
Everyone Jaco
students from the Czech Republic
and I'm excited to
reduce my uncertainty about the
new formulation that that
was introduced in this paper.
Or at least
it was the first time
I came across it in the active
inference literature,
as you mentioned,
about the different higher order and
lower order descriptions
and how do they conceptually map
to the different mathematical
mathematical formulation and also
to the psychological
ontology and
overall, just discuss
what that what that means and
what it might mean for
other applications as well.
And I'll pass on to Ryan.
I mean, I think so.
I'm I'm Ryan Smith.
I have some
research
Associate Professor
at the Laureate Institute
for Brain Research.
And so I'm the first author of this,
this paper.
So obviously I was definitely excited
about the ideas to write about it
or sufficiently motivated
at least to try to clarify
some things that I,
you know,
from my perspective
or sort of common misconceptions.
Yeah.
I mean, I'm,
I'm probably more going
to sit in the background here.
I'll just be here to answer questions
or clarify anything.
You know,
if something comes up where
something in the paper wasn't
wasn't especially clear because I didn't
I didn't do my job well enough.
So I'm. Yeah.
So I appreciate you guys being
willing to to talk about it.
Thanks.
Well, an overall comment
was we really appreciate
the clarity of the argument
and the writing
and the weaving together of the math
and the formalism
with the argument,
the rhetoric and the ontology.
That's that's prime time.
So I'll just jump right in.
And of course, anyone is
welcome to share their comments.
So, Dean, would you like to help us
contextualize with a big question?
Yeah.
So I think that there's
some questions surrounding
and I'm just going to take
some of the important quotes that I
left you from the paper,
the concern that activity
books psychology, because
they do not explicitly include terms
for desires
or other cognitive constructs
at a mathematical level of description.
So given that distinction
that there are active inference
motor control
which need not have desires
and are both psychology
and active inference models,
you have desires with them
for psychology.
That phrase that allows
constructs.
In could you
I think when you're talking and you like
turn away a little bit
or move back, it kind of cuts
the audio somewhat.
Yeah,
we'll try to continue from the given.
Thank you.
Okay.
So given the
there's a distinction
and active
inference models of motor control
which do not have desires
under folks
psychology and active interest,
models of decision processes
which do have desires with that culture.
So it's argued here.
Then the worry is that
if active inference models
can explain cognition
without appealing to constructs
can be mapped
onto the commonsense notion of desires.
Now to explain what that is
then that could be seen
as threat are intuitive folks.
I call like,
okay, my sense of ourselves as agents.
Such a situation
would also pressure
the traditional belief desire
intent model
of folk psychology
that is prominent in philosophy.
The body model
is a model of human agency
that explains what it means
to act intentionally.
So for me, I was introduced to the VDI
model as.
Yes, great.
And one
way that
I kind of saw
this big question, even pulling back
a layer is like
is active inference
recontextualizing, reframing,
augmenting, building on
what is already familiar.
In a sense
though, there are many folk psychologies
and I think that could be something
we go into.
Or is this the displacement
of some cherished framework
for some other construct
and the way that people speak like,
I want the cup of coffee
or something like that,
are we going to need
like a different word
for an active, compatible
folks, psychology and linguistics.
So Yaacov, any thoughts on that?
Well, I guess
one question I've
had was like
this even this formulation
of the
of the initial of the initial statement,
like given this distinction of motor
control, active
inference and
decision processes, active inference,
then we have this,
then we have this issue.
Well,
one thing
that I was a bit uncertain about was
whether this distinction
was made to fit the distinction.
That's within folk psychology.
There is some kind of ontology
for motor control
and an ontology for decision processes.
So therefore we try to split
active inference into these two parts
or whether there is actually
whether this
is distinction
follows directly from the same
mathematical formulation of
active.
Great.
I think there I think I think one thing
one thing to
to clarify as I think
I think the way that
this kind of given the distinction
followed by that here
I think
could be leading to a little bit
of a misunderstanding in a city.
The idea that there's a concern
about about a threat to folk psychology
comes not from that distinction.
It comes from
the fact
that there is
at the mathematical level
of description,
it doesn't look like there's
anything in there
that that's that's desire ish.
Right.
I mean, that's
where the worry comes from.
It doesn't really
the worry doesn't come
from the distinction
between motor control
and decision processes. Right.
The distinction between
motor control and decision process
is actually one thing
that by making that more explicit,
it actually helps to resolve the concern
or it shows
why it's not really a concern,
or that part of the concern
stems from
a failure to make that
distinction explicitly
so.
So just to kind of clarify that,
so that
I think the order
of the of the thought process
here is a little bit different
then than the way
the way it is in the paper.
Thanks helpful time.
And we'll clarify
and go through the argument in order to
so briefly, just the aims of the paper
as they present
it are to provide a brief review
of the historical progression
from predictive
coding to current octave
inference models
and show
that despite a superficial tension
when viewed at the mathematical level,
the active inference
formalism contains
terms that are readily identifiable
as desires and related
cognitive constructs
at the psychological level,
which is downstream
of that clarification
of the distinction
that Ryan just mentioned.
And then they discuss
the additional insights
offered by active inference
and the implications
it has for current
debates about active inference.
Any other names you'd want to add?
One, I think this is fine at the moment.
I mean, I'm sure things will come up
great.
And then
claims,
Jakob, could you read the claims?
Yeah.
So firstly that the apparent problem
posed by purely
diagnostic looking can't start
simply is not a problem.
There do not appear to be cases
where the phenotype
consistent prior expectation in data
often called
prior preferences
will ever conflict
with or existing predictions.
Then a traditional full cycle
psychological account
in which beliefs and desires
are integrated. Two point intentions.
The second claim
is that
what we have
referred to as the partially observable
mark of decision process
formulation of actin
is a corollary of the CEP
and it can be implemented
using prediction error minimization.
But there are many other aspects
of the FP
and many other theories
that fall under the umbrella
of predictive processing.
And in some
there are beliefs and desires
and the active inference framework.
Thanks.
And those are just a
few claims that we pulled out.
But many other declarative sentences
will also be claims.
I wouldn't necessarily call those
the primary claims of the paper.
I mean, they're
certainly statements that we make.
But I think I think the idea
that there isn't
I think the idea that
the apparent problem isn't a problem,
I think that's a claim.
And that it doesn't
that there won't be a conflict with
with an account
where you're combining beliefs
and desires to form intentions.
That's true.
This idea
about about what
falls under the predictive processing
umbrella with them,
I wouldn't necessarily say that's
something we're arguing
for in the paper.
It's just it's just something that
that matters
when you're trying to correctly frame
this kind of
this kind of debate, because,
you know,
predictive processing
is just a very generic term.
Right.
Like like
it doesn't refer to any particular
mathematical formalism.
It just refers to a really broad idea
that in some way
the brain's doing
some sort of predicting,
either with respect
to resolving problems
in perception or problems
in decision making or motor control.
And so so there really isn't
there's not enough
there's really just not enough
mathematical specificity
associated with predictive
processing as a term
to really even test
any predictions that it would make.
Right.
So I mean, I mean, what you
what you need to do
is take whatever
specific mathematical formalism,
what actual hypothesis
you're talking about
and evaluate and test claims to that.
Right?
So this that there just aren't
this aren't clear
like what even
it's just
pretty depressing
is just too general
and vague as the point.
So we can only really say
look under under
the current models used that are called
active inference, right?
So there's
a partially observable
markup decision process models
that minimize expected
free energy
as a way of making decisions. Right.
Those,
those arguably count as one particular
right theory or class of models
under the predictive
processing umbrella.
And we can evaluate claims
with respect to that model.
But you know what's true?
That doesn't need to be true of
the other
20 things out there that might,
you know,
might also fall
under a predictive processing umbrella.
So, I mean,
the main point is just
we need to evaluate
claims and predictions
and things like that
with respect to a specific model,
not with respect
to a kind of vague
general category of models.
Thank you.
Okay.
So just
rapidly through the abstract,
active inference offers
a unified theory of perceptions.
Learning and decision
making are
computational and neural levels
of description.
In this article,
we address the worry
that active inference
may be intention
with the belief desire,
intention by model
within folks psychology
because it does not include terms
for desires
or other cognitive constructs
at the mathematical level
of description.
To resolve this concern,
we first provide a brief review
of the historical progression
from predictive
coding to active inference,
enabling us to distinguish
between active inference
formulations of motor control and AI,
which need not have desires
under folk psychology
and active inference.
Formulations of decision processes
ie which do have desires under
or which are within folk psychology.
We then show that despite
a superficial tension,
when viewed at the mathematical
level of description,
the active inference
formalism contains terms
that are readily identifiable
as encoding both the objects of desire
and the strength of desire.
At the psychological level
of description,
we demonstrate this
with simple simulations
of an active inference
agents
motivated to leave a dark room
for different reasons.
Despite their consistency,
we further show how active inference
may increase
the granularity
of psychological descriptions
by highlighting distinctions
between drives
to seek information
versus reward,
and how it may also offer
more precise,
quantitative psychological predictions.
Finally,
we consider how the implicitly
quantitative components
of active inference
may have partial analogs, i.e.
as if desires
in other systems, describable
by the broader free energy
principle to which it conforms.
Here's the road map. So
the dot
zeros, all of them in the world,
wouldn't be enough to hit every stop.
So we will go through roughly
in order of these sections
and the section titles are listed here.
But Ryan, what was the thought
going into the ordering
or the structuring
and why there is such a comprehensive,
historical
and preliminary consideration section?
I mean, I mean, a lot of it
I mean, the vast
majority of these sections
are just kind of building up background.
Right.
I mean, especially in background,
kind of see. Right.
Where where the you know, both both
I think
historically where, you know,
potential misunderstandings
might come from,
you know, and also and also
just enough of the providing,
enough of the formalism.
You know,
one part of the formalism
does kind of build on another writer
to see why them,
you know,
to see whether the
the apparent problem just isn't there.
Right.
So, I mean, the vast
majority of these sections
are just very preliminary,
just kind of building up
so that the reader has the information
necessary to
understand the argument, mainly
only the last couple of sections
that really,
really are the meat of the
argument itself.
I mean, so for example, just section
two, you know, the
ah what we just said
from the predictive coding
act of inferences,
just kind of highlighting how you know,
these initial is a
phase in brain
as implemented
or predictive
coding was purely a model of perception,
right?
So then, you know, so not people
but a lot of times you'll see,
especially in the
older literature
and in some philosophy literature,
you know, predictive processing somehow
both refers to predictive coding,
but then also is talked
about as though it's
as though it's
the same thing as active inference.
Or they'll be these kinds of ideas where
if you just extend
predictive coding as kind of a
for the way it's talked about
as a kind of way of thinking about what
the whole brain does,
you know, then all of a sudden,
you know, controlling the body
ends up also just being something
about predicting what the body will do.
But but and
especially when described that way.
Right.
It sounds like something like
desire and motivation and goals
and things like that
are just kind of completely out
the window.
It's very hard
to make sense of what
how a system like
that would even work right.
And so it's and part of that,
I think, is because there's some,
you know, some
the way that certain things are written
and some of the literature
can be a little bit
confusing or it's not it's not too hard
to understand why,
you know, these sorts of you know,
these sorts of misunderstandings
could, you know, could happen.
But but but the section
really, really is to show how,
you know, initially, right,
when you're trying to move
from predictive coding again,
which is purely a model of perception,
it's not about decision making.
It's not about action selection.
It's not even about motor control.
Right.
It's just it's
just a Bayesian,
just a theory of how the brain
can do approximate Bayesian
inference and perception.
Yeah.
How that was initially
just extended to say,
hey, like if the brain works
this way, then, you know, how do you
how do you get a system
that actually controls the body
using the same generic architecture?
Right.
And so that,
you know, the story that then, you know,
and you know,
some other people
started
trying to put together was
the story
about how you can use predictions,
you know, descending predictions
if weighted appropriately.
Right.
As a way of
essentially setting
the target states of the body.
Right.
Like like
is this kind of the way I see
it talked about is,
you know,
I predict that my arm will be here,
but really it's down here.
But if I wait there correctly,
that it'll kind of like,
you know, you'll kind of control
the set point in a reflex arc.
So your arm kind of moves up
and transition, right?
But but that's
just a theory about how you can use
a descending prediction signal
to essentially act
as a motor command signal. Right.
There's nothing in that at all
that that's deciding
what that prediction ought to be.
Right.
There's nothing deciding what that
what which motor command
should should be the one
that's getting sent down.
And in a
and the with the form of a prediction.
Right?
So, so again,
so even there, it's
just a theory
about how you can use predictions
as motor currents, right?
Like there's now
a very big distinction between that
and whatever the system
is on top of that.
Right, is deciding, okay,
what motor command
but what motor prediction. Right.
Do I send?
And so does making,
you know,
making making that clear, right?
Because around 2015,
there was this big shift
right from this from this act
where from active inference
being talked about as a
a just kind of a motor control process.
Right?
Like a
like a story about how you can extend
predictive coding to
know also do motor commands, right?
Like from that to,
you know,
this larger, more comprehensive decision
making models
which are the current on the based
and those which was all aim to show
very explicitly you have something that
you know in the mathematics.
It just does, right?
It specifies the goals of the system.
It's pretty hard to get around
the fact that you need something,
a system need something like goals.
Right.
Because it has to evaluate
somehow
why one decision
is going to be better than another.
Right.
The only way it can really do
that is with respect
to how likely it is
to get whatever the system wants.
So so it's just
I mean,
in my in my view,
it's it's very difficult to see how
how you could ever get
a system to be able to evaluate
one action
as better than another
without having some sort of
target state.
And and so you can
call, right, like the target states,
an active inference,
a type of prior belief.
But at the end of the day,
it's functional role is to specify
what what observations
are better than what. Right.
So I mean,
you can really think
of active inferences
as using this kind of trick
in a certain sense, right?
Of specifying
desired outcomes
in the form
of a probability distribution,
because that helps keep everything
fully, fully, fully Bayesian.
Right.
But it's not it's not sampling
functional belief, right?
It's encoding in a higher probability
just means right.
Like the better, more rewarding outcome.
So so a lot of it is just
kind of
working step by step
through of kind
of the historical progression.
So you can see where
the misunderstanding could come from
and then also through
the current formalism
so that you can see exactly where those
where the,
you know,
the goal states are encoded
in terms of something
with the form
of a probability distribution.
Thank you.
The keywords are active inference,
folk psychology, predictive processing,
Bayesian beliefs and desires.
So now we're going to jump in
and some of the slides
have a lot of text topically arranged,
so we won't need to read all of the text
on many of the slides,
but especially
if somebody wants to pull out
like one of the highlighted sections
and like bring it to our attention.
That would be awesome.
So
and also, Ryan,
thanks a lot for that great
historical overview.
And I think there's there's
so much more to be
going into
about what happened before 2015
and what happened
in the last seven years.
In fact,
I think you covered
many of the key points
in what you just described here,
which had to do
with the development
of the predictive coding framework
into understanding brain and body.
Is there anything that anyone else
wants to add about these points?
Great. Then
all discussions and
zeros are like a two way street
where some people with active inference
familiarity are learning about new ideas
and frameworks.
And also people
who might have familiarity
with of a broadly
used area
outside of active
are learning about active.
So for both directions on that freeway,
it's important to understand
what is the target
non active framework
that's being juxtaposed and found.
Concordance is with active inference.
So the article is addressing the worry
that active models
may be in tension
with the belief desire, intention model,
and there are some consequences
to that worry.
In other words,
given some priors, it's a founded worry.
Would anyone like to summarize
what the belief, desire,
intention model is?
And you should, Daniel, because you
I think you put this slide together.
Ryan What led you to select
the BVI model?
And I wondered about
almost this tension or paradox
with like it's
folk psychology, it's
about what the people think.
But we're going to do a citation
and one specific academic acronym
for what people think.
So is this like the main game in town
for folk psychology
from an academic perspective,
or what is the PDI
and what led you to select that
rather than like a small portfolio
of alternate folk psychologies?
I think that, you know,
our intention
model is just a very kind of generic,
but also widely known
account of trying to capture
folk psychology.
And it's it's kind of a
it's a it's a it's a major
sort of target of a lot of discussion
within philosophy of mind.
But but I mean, it's
just very generic, right?
I mean, just this idea of,
you know, what
what are the
what are the necessary ingredients
to make a decision?
Well, you know,
I have to have some beliefs
about how the world is
and about some desires
about how the world
I would like it to be.
And my intention involves
integrating those two things. Right.
And then
and then if all goes
if all goes
well in terms of translating intention
into controlling the body,
then I'll act out,
know something according to my intention
right then in simple,
like the example that you'll often hear
is just something like,
you know, I desire some ice cream.
You know,
I believe that
there's an ice cream truck,
you know, down the road,
you know, given those two things and
and necessarily those two things, right.
I can inform, interpret
and form
an intention to go,
you know,
walk over to the ice cream
truck and buy some ice cream.
So how many questions,
how else you know,
are you going to explain why
I went over to the truck
to buy the ice cream?
Literally just is
that is the general sort of thing
that when we're reasoning
about other people's
decisions, other people's
behavior, and
trying to figure out, okay,
why did this person do what they did?
You know,
we're assuming it's a voluntary action
or assuming it's
not because there are arm spasms or,
you know,
because they have some
like really highly ingrained habit
or compulsion or something like that.
Right.
I mean, we're talking
about voluntary behavior
and that is just the way. Right.
That we tend to reason
about how people do what they do.
You know, either once I
when somebody does something that's
we think is weird, right,
then usually we have to explain that
in terms of, okay, well,
they just believe something
that was incorrect, right?
Or they had some really funny desire.
Right? That I don't really
you know, it's it's tends to be
one of those sorts of things, right?
I mean, I mean,
I don't know a lot of other,
you know, separate
folks, psychological models
that would entail
anything different than us
at a very generic level.
And it's also exactly the sort of thing
that that people try to contrast
active inference
with where where instead of, you know,
belief, desire
and desires coming together
to form intentions.
Instead it'd be something like
one kind of belief
in another kind of beliefs
come together to form an intention,
which again, for a lot of reasons is,
you know, confusing and rightfully so
when it's presented that way.
Makes yes.
This QUESTION
So Brian,
when we've had some conversations
with other authors in other papers
where we've talked about the scale
three formalism
and we've also talked a little bit
about the sort of scale friendly
times when you have defined that history
and that context.
What you just
mentioned was sort of the generic
generalized sense that the BDA
umbrella provides.
You're not saying that scale three
Quantifying creation and a generic
way of modeling
something are the same thing.
But what I think I'm like,
without putting words in your mouth,
are you saying that the scale freeness
as it moves to something
more scale friendly, sweeps up
some of that generic
big tent idea or model and now
moves it along, allows you to sort of
parse and be specific
and precise, precise,
but also be able to generalize
as you move through those
you know, quantification
of the distribution
and density and such,
because that's kind of
what I was reading into it.
I just want to make sure that I got
it was kind of
maybe you can help me clean
that up a bit.
I mean, I really don't know that
anything that we're saying
really depends on our even
gets into a lot
of those sorts of specifics.
I mean, really
and really all we're saying
is, is that, you know,
if you want to take
a model
like the current pack of insurance
formulas in the current
kind of like vanilla formalism, right?
So in terms of interest,
the standard one or scaled up claim,
it doesn't really matter.
It is if you want to use
the vanilla active inference framework
to actually model
some sort of voluntary decision
process in a human rights in.
A lot of my work has to do with people
modeling behavior on decision
making tasks
right then have to do with the person.
The person has the goal of maximizing,
you know, how much money they want
or maximizing
some sort of social reward.
Something like the idea is
just that when you're trying to
if you're going to take an active
inference model
and you're going to use it to model,
successful model actual human behavior
when they're making decisions, then
there's always going to be
a mapping between the different elements
in the active inference model
of voluntary behavior that for the
whatever the prior prior
preference distribution is,
you just set that so that it just to
the level of reward
and
so so there's really
nothing about any super scale
or anything like that.
This is much more generic.
It's just
if you're going to use active inference
to model voluntary choice, then
it will always be something analogous
to a belief and a desire
because that's just what you need
to model to model voluntary behavior.
It's true that, you know,
that's probably
if you're
if you actually
were going to try to capture something
kind of
like more of the actual architecture
on the brain,
as opposed to just
this kind
of like voluntary decision
process aspect.
I mean, I'm
sure there's a lot of
kind of hierarchy below
that under that, right,
that's translating
or abstracts, policy selection processes
into whatever
the dynamic signals are that
that end up controlling
moment by moment, muscle movements and
things like that.
But the point is, is that below
a lot of this kind of top level
where you're doing policy selection
at that point,
you don't really need the desires
anymore, right?
You just need the policy to specify
whatever though
motor commands are going down
that can take the form of predictions.
So I don't
I don't know if that helps,
but it's just, it's
just that in a certain level,
in any kind of hierarchy of a model
that's going to actually
be applicable successfully
to human behavior
and at the level of policy selection and
prior preferences
will just inform the desired outcomes.
They'll just encode
the goals
that the agents are trying to reach.
And the policy
that's chosen
will be evaluated
as being the most likely policy, because
it's the thing that's predicted to
have the highest probability of
getting the desired
generating the desired observation.
I'm
if I may also comment on that,
and I'm not sure if this is
answering your question, Dean,
but the way I thought about it
when I was reading the paper
was that part of the reason why
the believe,
desire, intention model kind of works?
It works well for for mapping
the active inference
ontology to the full psychology ontology
is because it's the discrete model in
that it separates
these, these different,
these different parts.
And, and,
and I think that also
might have motivated the choice to
consider mainly this preplanned piece
and describe the decision
this decision active inference in that
in that way as well,
because then this discrete model
can be more easily
mapped to say the discrete model of
the MVP that that's described like a,
like a factor graph.
I'm, I'm not sure I,
I was wondering how this would map to
continuous tasks as well and.
Well, I mean, I mean,
I think the I mean part of the I mean,
part of the part of the reason
why you need something discrete,
right, is as actions discrete, right?
I mean,
there's either one or this powerful view
or this model, right?
So those,
those just are sort of necessarily
right.
I mean, you get in
a continuous
database is worthwhile
or are appropriate
at lower levels in a hierarchy.
You know,
when you're talking
about kind of dynamics
and motor movement,
then you mix
in a set point of some reflex ARCore
or when you're trying to estimate
something in perception
that just
just as a continuous quantity, right?
Like brightness or orientation
or things like that.
But, but the level of,
at the level of decision making
and models are necessarily discrete.
I mean I mean, there is
you know,
there are
there are kind of hybrid models, right,
that are out there in the literature.
For example,
you know,
Hezbollah, several papers
using these sorts of models where the
the kind of policy
at the higher level,
which is which is in a discrete model
and generates
some observation, then sets that point.
Right, for some continuous
or some continuous low level model
that then can end up in a, in a way
that's kind of like this kind of
story, you know,
like move
the eyes around the car
to different locations
and things like that.
So, so I, I kind of think that
the discrete ness is the, or the, the,
the reason why
things move to a discrete size
based architecture
is just because of the necessary
what's necessary with respect
to a model of policy collection,
because it it's kind of all or none.
Just to keep the .00 ish,
we're going to move a lot faster
through the following slides.
And there's many important questions
in the chat and, and also arising.
So we'll just kind of carry on
more rapidly
so people can
pick up on these key points in the zero.
And we have a lot of
time to explore soon.
Section two
from predictive
coding to active inference
traces the history and the developments
from various fields.
And just one sentence here
that the
Dean and I both highlighted on at
then Dean, let you describe the button.
Was that
crucially, for the purposes
of this paper,
the first generation
active inference
was not a theory of decision making.
It did not explain how we decide or plan
where to move our body.
It only explained
how body movements can be executed
using the predictive coding apparatus.
Once a decision has been made.
So how did you connect
that to the bottom? Right.
Yeah.
So if you're on a if you're on a
some sort of a website
and you have
to pass through to something.
My question was based on that statement,
when the expectation
is to know
that you've actually crossed
the threshold, you've moved
beyond one page,
and there's an expectation that there's
something that you've validated
or confirmed or whatever.
Is the feedback that you received.
Does that have
how how does the
person who's actually expecting that
they're on the other side?
What kind of feedback mechanism
do they need to for that confirmation?
Is tactile feedback enough?
Do they need
some sort of a
visual confirmation as well?
Like what is the what's the
it is there
because we're talking about thresholds.
Is that different
for every single person
or is it sort sort of expectations built
in depending upon the kind of situation
that you're dealing with?
I do know that with that,
the idea
that like changes are saved
or links are copied,
sometimes the click isn't enough
to give people confidence
that in fact
that process is carried through.
I mean, I would
I would say
that I mean,
a lot of those questions
are really empirical,
empirical questions, modeling questions.
You know, I mean,
in terms of in terms
of how you would model
that sort of thing
or get you to specify what observations
kind of tactile
you specify, what observations
counts at all.
And what ends up being thresholds
for inspection evidence
and things like that.
Just that's not the way it processes,
just how the dynamics
naturally unroll in the model
under whatever the model parameters
action is. So, so
you'll hit a threshold faster
if the mapping between observation,
whatever observations
and states is more precise, for example,
I mean there's,
you know,
in relation
to in relation to that
when we're doing
policy selection right,
we also have to check and see
whether things are actually going
as we expected them
to go under a choice of policy.
Right. That's possible.
That you choose
policy one
and you start
to get the subsequent observations
and they are actually match for
you expected,
you know, given that you've
chosen policy one,
in which case
you'll update your beliefs
or perceptual inferences
that might influence
how you act going forward.
So, so but the specifics about,
you know,
what's enough,
whether it's visual
or tactile or anything like that,
I mean, those are
those are really just
empirical questions
that would have to be answered
in studies as opposed to
something about model choices.
Okay.
So there was really not a
good enough thing
when you did the darkroom aspect of it,
like the reading about
prepared to take on, right?
Like somebody
was prepared to take on the risk
because they really urgently
wanted the ice cream versus
the person who was like,
yeah, I'm agnostic, right?
So that's
maybe that's kind of what I was
because this was on the second
reading of your paper, right?
So I was kind of now back
from further down in the paper.
So well I into that.
Yeah, we'll go in order
because we're mentioning things
that we haven't brought up yet,
but let's continue on
and we'll return to that.
And Ryan, I,
I also
agree that in any specific case, it's
going to be a model parameter position.
Some of these are very difficult
to answer in the abstract
model selection setting
here, the
distinction between motor
active inference
and decision active
inference is introduced and all allow
Jacob to just convey one pass.
What is the difference
between motor active inference
and decision active inference?
So I'm not sure
whether I can
say much that hasn't been said yet.
But in a briefly, the motor
active inference is does well.
As already mentioned
it does not consider
design desires in the in
both the active inference
and psychological sense as
was then connected in the bit
in the paper.
But
also it is my understanding
that the motor control
version of active inference is modeled
continuously, like the models of
of the movement of individual muscles,
which does not entail decision making.
So it's modeled with
a continuous time
rather than in discrete time,
and that's decision making.
And if, as
Ryan already said as well,
is all about decision making.
So it describes the discrete
process of decision making with
prior beliefs and preferences.
And it can I
and it can be model
at different, different
levels of cognition as well is one thing
that I'm still a bit uncertain
about how we can move
through these different layers
while still keeping
the same mathematical formulation,
but I think we'll probably get to
that in the other slides.
Yep.
We're going to continue with this
distinction of am I for motor active
inference and I for the decision
active inference.
Here we're showing some key sections
from the paper and some citations.
I think we will continue on
without going into this in depth,
but it describes
some of the specific model quantities
that are being
described in active inference formalism,
and we're going to come to them
when we look at some equations
in the coming slides
in section
three, preliminary considerations,
two broad points are introduced
and we might show
a second one on a later slide.
How can we think, Ryan,
about what
is said here
that decision making models
are largely taken to describe
sub personal non conscious processes?
And also it was asked in the chart,
not that we have to address it
now by doing it
has active
inference produced
a single reasonable model of a qualia.
So when we're thinking about this
first broad point that was made here,
where is experience
and what is the distinction
between the personal
and the sub personal in I
um.
Well, I mean, so
there's a couple
different questions
you asked there
and I don't necessarily
think they're synonymous.
So, you know,
when you said,
I think the first question you
asked for something about
has active
inference provided
some sort of explanation or model of
of qualia that would be satisfactory?
And I'm in a strong stance on the sense
another in the sense of quality
as an explanation
for the hard problem of consciousness,
then I think active inferences
in the same place
as anyone else
and that no one
has a good explanation
for, for
how to deal
with the hard problem of consciousness.
Right?
I mean, like it's
massive literature out there,
but I think everyone thinks it's
just as mysterious as ever.
So so no. Right.
I mean, on the other hand,
I mean, know myself and others
have published multiple papers
showing how you can successfully
use active
inference models
to to model conscious access processes.
Right.
So the distinction between
when the brain is representing
something unconsciously versus
when it's representing
something consciously,
you know, in that it can
self-report, right?
What it's representing.
Can you use the information
to make voluntary choices?
And we've shown that
those sorts of models
are able to reproduce
like empirical results
and like EEG studies and MRI studies
and things like that.
That and that also can make novel
neurophysiological predictions,
some of which seem like they,
you know,
in some subsequent work,
we have
empirical support for those predictions.
So so in terms of providing a,
you know, a
what seems like a useful account
of the processes
associated with
what people self-report
that they consciously experience
and, and the brain basis for that.
I think active inference as the
least the starting, you know, a starting
starting point for
for being useful
and explaining those sorts of things.
But you know why one little posterior
and set of model versus
another posterior
in a model
actually corresponds
to like the experience
of red versus blue or something.
I mean, no, I don't.
I think active inferences is
not any better than anyone else.
Know any other model for that question.
The
I guess
the second thing
that you asked had to do with
it's kind of a related question of
why it's the case
that one model has to do
with a conscious process
for his unconscious process.
And
the best never really got there.
And you know
what, what falls
out of the models that we have
shown really
this has to do with temporal scale,
you know,
so there's still
there will be a certain level
of temporal
representation in a hierarchical model
that that integrates enough
and represents regularities
over a long enough timescale
that I can contribute to
in a sort of prospective.
And it will be sufficiently compact
to generate things
like self-reports, right?
So I mean, think about
how complicated and temporally extended
we're performing and
choosing to report something like,
you know,
I see something green in
front of me, right?
I mean, it's a very complicated
and really deep
and narrow
type of policy to select
and it requires
integrating a bunch of information
from stuff at lower levels
that's happening over faster timescales.
So at a minimum, right,
you just need to be
at a level
of representation
or the regularities are sufficiently
sufficiently long and
especially temporally deep
and then have access
to all the relevant information
you need to integrate
to be able to generate
records like that.
Whereas, whereas much of the other
kind of little pieces in the model,
right, like
the generated
say like expected error
for like variational for energy
gradients and things like that that
people like all like surprise, right?
I mean, no one's claiming
that and often
they will not relate in any way
to people's conscious reports
about the like surprise
because conscious reports about feeling
surprise will have to do
with representations
of surprises states.
Right, as opposed to
some sort of prediction error like
gradient minimization process.
So
thanks.
Also in Section three,
there are several clarifications
and some seeds that are planted,
namely if computational
and folk
psychological predictions converge
and no other available theory
can account for behavior equally well,
this could entail
the mathematical structure of AI
as more than a convenient tool,
instead that it corresponds
to the true information
processing structure
underlying in enabling
folk psychology and related abilities.
And this is really nicely put here that
the crucial point remains
that one should not
conflate mathematical
and psychological levels of description.
However, dry models
might nonetheless offer
more detailed information
about the true form
of folk, psychological categories
and processes, and then they add that
their aims are to demonstrate
that there's a clear ice morph ism
between the elements of DIY models
and those of the body model,
and then show how
provided one does not assume
probability distributions
in computational models
must be identified with beliefs
at a psychological level,
there will be no tension
between DJI and VDI, and that comparison
or or juxtaposition
is clarified by separating
AI from DJI has been mentioned.
Anything else
before we start to jump
into some of the formalism
and keeping all of this in mind?
I guess I had one question on
our on the
on which
ontology we're working with.
When we say there's
a isomer present
between the elements of die models
and those of the VDI model,
because I think there are multiple ways
to interpret this one.
One thing that I'm wondering about
is whether this means
that we can basically construct
a mathematical formulation
of the of the BD model
that is like a
subset of active inference.
Or maybe
maybe there are certain certain elements
of the BD model that aren't necessarily
encapsulated by the Nocturnes
that weren't discussed in this paper.
And what
that would
mean in terms of formulating
this mathematical,
mathematical formulation
of, of the BD model.
So I mean, what the isomer as I'm just
means is
tell me the description at one level
and I'll be able to translate it for you
very quickly
and directly
into whatever the description
as of the other level
in both directions.
Right.
I mean, so that just means,
you know, tell me tell me what?
Now tell me what it is that you want.
You know,
if I say,
do you want ice cream
or do you want a pizza? Right.
Tell me tell me that you like.
If you tell me that you like
you want pizza
twice as much as you like ice cream,
then it's very easy to just put
a four
in the, you know, in the distribution,
in the preference
distribution
over the observation of pizza
and the two for ice cream
and then soft mac it and log it.
Right and then like,
you know,
there's that's the description, right?
So just in a very direct way,
it just encodes relative desires
for one thing versus another.
Now tell me your beliefs are right.
I mean,
do you believe the pizzas to the left
or to the right?
I can put that in
as the different categories of it
and states
that are going in
for a distribution over. Right.
So like it's just
the point
is, is that in either direction, right?
Give me the full
psychological description.
I can translate it
very straightforwardly
using the same elements every time
as being desires or beliefs.
Give it to me.
At the at the mathematical level,
I can translate that into description
in terms of beliefs and desires. Right.
I mean, it's just it's just 1 to 1.
I can't think of an example offhand
where
there would be any kind
of like mismatch or an ability
for one to account for the other.
But, you know, it's
kind of hard to prove a negative, right?
So I mean, maybe
you can give me an example,
but I can't think of one.
Awesome. Yeah.
Yeah.
I was just going to say
that I can really
think of an example right now.
I, I, I just,
I find it
really interesting with the usage of,
of just the word is more pleasant
because that like,
as you,
as you said, it's just
a by by direction and subjective map.
So it's basically equivalent.
It's just set in a different way.
So I can imagine that
meaning that we can basically
instead of the Wikipedia page
where the body I'm
all using all of these terms
like believe, desire, intention,
it could just be a set of active
inference equations and that's the body.
I'm also because it's an exorcism.
Right?
I mean, literally your your beliefs
or just your cues. Right.
And your and your desires are just
your right.
I mean I mean, and,
you know, the way that we've
we and others
have tended to write it now.
Right.
Is to
literal is just explicitly to say
like that
desires are or the preference
distribution is to have a given C
right or C
is just a matrix
that defines your preferences, right?
So I mean, it's a lot clearer to do that
than to just
just leave and just plow, right.
I think that's part of the confusion
it says, is that
it's not clear
where the preference come from,
but there just is just because
the conditional on this other thing.
See
and C can be fixed or learned.
But that's the basis
of the calculation there.
Yeah.
Here we get into section four,
variational and expected
free energy considerations
and in large script
we see the variational
free energy equation.
Then what is the skydiver doing?
And during the one in the two,
we'll unpack
more about the exact terms
and and what is coming into
and coming out of this equation.
But just
as an appetizer
here, what's the skydiver doing?
Well, then I've got the order here.
I just put through that endeavor
because I like the the
I don't think it's a metaphor,
but the analogy of how
so how do you respond
when you jump out of the airplane
and, you know,
your parachute is not to work?
Do you
do you go ahead first
and really attack it? Or like what now?
What are you doing in terms of
what your expectations are?
So maybe, maybe
that that was a good analogy.
Ryan Maybe.
But what like so what were you
where were you going with that?
Because yeah.
Well, I mean, I think the point
the point of
those sorts of examples
are just to just to
sort to put this to
to show why it's not
it's not really correct
to think about them like prior,
you know, this prior
preference distribution,
even though it's,
you know,
it's again, it's cast as our belief.
Right.
And it's not really appropriate
to think about that as a as a
a a belief, right?
I mean, a
or an expectation
at a any
at a psychological level description.
So you can and the way to contrast that.
Right, is
you can say like
like the person in a model
where they don't want
to fall to the ground and die.
Right.
That would be
the end of that would be the right.
It's your preference
not to have the observation
of hitting the ground and dying,
but where you are.
Right.
Is is your cue about given high, right.
It's what do I expect to observe
given that I choose this policy versus
that policy. Right.
So that's the that's the,
you know, the belief part. Right.
So what I expect,
given that I do this or that
and how close is that to
how much does that diverge from what I
what I want? Right.
Which for me,
all that's just a
it's just a clear
example of how your your belief,
the expectations that your desire,
the expectations come apart
and and it just doesn't work conceptual
to think one
is think of one as like the same kind of
kind of thing as the other.
Yeah.
I just saw it as if I'm not
going to get a soft landing.
How big of a crater can I can I create?
Well, that's.
Not that
is going to be packed
into your reference distribution.
Right. Right.
You would have some desire for enough
to make a big,
you know, conditional on
you're going to die. Right.
You know,
you'd prefer
to make a big crater
than a small crater.
And that would
still just go in your favor.
All right. So.
Yeah, yeah.
Jacob, I was just wondering,
and this might be me
thinking thinking differently
or not too deeply
about the equation, rather.
But in this in this formulation
where it's a variation of free energy
for each policy, I have pie.
Does that
does that imply
when in the last sentence
on the slide that free energy,
the functional beliefs
and a function of observations.
That doesn't mean that the free energy
is essentially
a function of three variables,
but in this case
we are only writing it off of PI because
it's always and it's it's clear
that it's a function of
of beliefs and observations
or should be think of it more as
just a function of
each policy.
I mean, the way it's written here,
I'm going to think that
straightforward way to think about it is
I mean, it literally just means that
using this equation,
you will calculate a different value
for each policy, right?
Mean that's really like you just
there will be
you're going to be computing
some some variational free energy value
for each policy
and that's going to make up
a distribution over policies.
And and I mean, the
the tricky thing I guess here is,
is, is that, you know, this isn't about
this is an F of f apply here
isn't about making decisions. Right.
This is just about something
like evaluating evidence for,
you know, for various policies
because you
you can't
you calculate F
when you already have the observation.
Right.
So you can't relate to
this prospective decision
making thing with f.
So this is just basically
a way of describing how how underage
policy your beliefs will change
or wouldn't change right under
when you get conditional on each new
observation that you got.
And, and so it's not.
Yeah.
So all it denotes really is it's just,
you know,
you have a value of F for each policy
and that makes it a distribution.
And that takes us to
G expected free energy.
The letter after F
and as shown here not sure
if there's another reason for
why it's G.
This is
equation 2.6
from the active inference
textbook, just for reference
with some other versions
of how G is framed.
G is a prospective value and they write.
Decision
making does not only require beliefs
about past and present states,
it also
requires making predictions
about future states
and future observations.
This requires taking the average i.e.
expected free energy
g of pi
given anticipated
outcomes under each policy
that one might choose.
And there's
a lot to
say on expected free energy.
What is just one short note
that somebody could add
or Ryan, why was it placed here?
I'm not sure I understand the question.
Like why?
Why is why is expected
free energy required?
Why is variational free energy
not enough?
Unexpected for energy is
just as just what the system
is trying to minimize
when it's selecting policy. Right?
So, I mean, it's just trying to
I mean, in
I mean, this decomposition
right here is often called like the risk
plus ambiguity decomposition.
But
I guess
I like
I think that I think that showing the
the risk
the risk term here provides a
nice lesson for, again,
the separation between beliefs
and desires and active inference because
your your set out
the the term underlined and
and read them, right.
So the divergence between a given pie
and zero, right?
I mean, that's just saying that,
you know, how different
are the observations
I expect
given that I choose a given policy
and how different
how how different is that?
How different
or I expect that to be from my
my preferences or my desires, right?
So the, the closer those are together,
the more the more similar.
I expect the observations
to be under a policy
to my preferred observations,
the smaller that's going to be.
And so if I'm trying to
select the policy that minimizes
G, right,
then that means I'm going
to select the policy
that's going to get me as close,
that's going to get me as close
to my preferred
observations as possible. Right?
So literally just
is that cale divergence literally
just as trying to choose the policy
that brings beliefs closest to desires.
Very nice.
And then what does the blue term mean?
And that's just an entropy term, right?
So it's just basically saying
that the is
what drives information
seeking or part of what
drives information.
So again, it's just it's just yeah,
basically
the agents just
driven to choose policies
that also are going to generate
more precise expected
observations, observations
that are going to disambiguate
states more more easily.
Great.
Here, we'll explore it
more in the dark one.
But there's
a description
of the posterior
probability distribution over policies
of PI and an expression involving
the soft max symbol with the sigma.
We'll return to that later.
But this is just so that we can cover
like the key experiments
and the simulation results today
of this is also one other
area of formalism
we can explore in the coming discussions
about precision
and the relationship of beta and gamma
and what the convergence towards means.
But we won't go there.
There is precision
parameter in this model.
Let's go to the dark room problem and
many lines of PDF screen
and ink has been written
on the dark room
in the active world since perhaps
first at all 2012
and also outside of active.
And
they write
in a nutshell,
the concern is
that if agents
only act to minimize prediction error
as opposed to acting
under the impetus
of a cognitive desire like state,
then they ought to simply seek out
very stable, predictable environments
such as a dark room and stay there.
Would anybody like to add
anything about this dark room problem,
or what is the relationship
between dark, spastic and cognitive
ontology and active?
I mean,
are you just asking
what like what those words mean or what?
Like, I don't know.
How do you how do you use these words?
I mean I mean, it's just a term
that refers to the leafy,
you know,
like epistemic sorts of things, right?
So so a dark tastic ontology
would be an ontology that includes
leafy things, right?
Whereas, whereas, uh,
you know, cognitive just refers to Yeah.
Being like targeted
toward something, right?
Like something about desires or,
you know,
something things you want versus
don't want things you like
versus don't like. Right?
So
it's just, you know, when we say it's
apparently pure access
to ontologies, you're saying
it might look
as though superficially like the
the ontology
proposed an act active inference
like the things that exist
in active inference are purely belief.
That's all that means.
Great.
And it's applied in the setting
of this dark room
for the following two slides.
Dean,
help us understand
what concerns are addressed
and what the child
on the top right of the slides is doing.
Yeah, well,
so I'm not going to go through all of
all of the text,
but essentially
this was my introduction
to the dark room problem
because it was kind of the opposite
of all my experience,
which is that
I tend to find people that were curious
and we're trying to move away from
information
level leveling
off or
or being static to information gain.
So first of all, I had to learn what
but the
what the argument was about
why people would actually,
you know, who are normally social,
why they would move away
from that social realm
and into this sort of dark space
under the car,
under the idea that
active inference is actually implies
that's what people would do.
And then secondly was
I was kind of trying to tie it
into the idea of the refrigerator
and where it is.
And until you actually and Dan,
you and I talked about this a bit,
the pragmatic piece of
till you actually open
the refrigerator door,
which is on that kind of the next slide,
you don't really
I mean you can have a belief
that there's
something of value in there,
but it can turn out that
when you open the door or Monti raises
the curtain,
the thing that you were expecting
turns out to be a value,
but not necessarily
of that thing that you were.
You are setting yourself up to believe.
And so that that young individual
spitting the coin out.
And maybe I
guess I was just
trying to be a little bit
facetious there
that it holds value,
but it doesn't hold the same kind of
tasty value
as, say,
having a lick of an ice cream cone.
So again, it was
it was trying to move away
from the idea
that the belief is stuff alone is satis
satisfactory or necessary.
I always get those too mixed up, but I.
I was just trying to reinforce the idea
that you kind of need
to have both
so that you can compare and contrast,
so that you get a sense
of what a person or
what an agent is doing
as they're
getting past some of those shrouds
or some of those
non observables into the observable
state.
Thanks.
We'll keep going.
This is unpacking
some of the concerns
about the apparent pure
docs Gnostic belief
oriented ontology of actin.
So Ryan described earlier
like is it about beliefs colliding
and if so,
if it's purely diagnostic,
then where is this desire and
is there anything
else that anybody wants to add here?
I would maybe
comment that I think this also
relates to your
to the earlier thing
that was discussed, how
this confusion might stem
from people misinterpreting
or messing
confusing the terms,
predictive processing
and active of inference.
And I feel like this addresses
it as well, where
if we just if it's only beliefs,
then there is obviously a concern
that once we're in a dark room,
we can because
if we're only in the regime
of predictive processing,
there is no way for us to
move to a different state
or there isn't.
The formalism that that describes
planning an action.
But as
I guess
we'll get to in the other slides
when we do include this planning,
we have,
these are like
terms appearing within
the mathematical formulation as well.
Great.
To be clear.
It's not like they're thrown
in ad hoc, right?
They emerge
naturally as like necessary
components of America,
you know,
like using this sort of framework
or building it out to involve planning.
So it's not
like they emerge
naturally and necessarily it's not a
it's not because someone's
just kind of talking them on
great.
And this is referring
to that minimization of G.
The minimization of G drives
the agent to seek out observations
that will reduce uncertainty
about the best way to subsequently
bring about
phenotype, congruent
or preferred outcomes.
So that's the information seeking.
Another way to put this
is that under DNI,
an agent doesn't simply seek
to minimize prediction error
with respect
to its current sensory input.
It seeks instead
to minimize prediction
error with respect to its global
beliefs about the environment,
which entails
seeking out
observations that are expected
to generate prediction errors
such that uncertainty is minimized
for the generative model as a whole.
And another
aspect of this
type of global prediction
error minimization process
is that it pertains
not only to beliefs
about states in the present,
but also to beliefs about the past
and in the future.
And so this is leading
to one of the claims,
which is that
in addition to desires,
die captures folk
psychological experiences
associated with the drive
to both know about one's current states
and learn
what will happen
when choosing to move to other states,
among other parameters,
in a generative model.
Let's go into this generative model
and come to the darkroom
simulation itself
and we'll
unpack it more in future times.
But the prior over policies of PI
the right that
when the agent
repeatedly chooses a policy,
this term increases the probability
that the agent
will continue to select
that policy in the future.
At the level of the formalism,
this corresponds
to an agent coming to expect
that it will choose a policy
simply because it has chosen that policy
many times in the past.
This can be thought of as a type of
hybridization process,
but it doesn't have
any direct connection
to preferred outcomes
because EFI
Pi is not informed by other beliefs
in the agents model.
So here's the partially observable
Markov decision process,
just one representation of it,
and is sort of floating
there, influencing but not being by.
And we had some interesting discussions
which we can return to another time
about how we might be able to assess
whether somebody
is engaging in a behavior
because they simply have habitually
engaged in that behavior.
But they understand the actual mapping
of, how policies
relate to outcomes, or in another case
where somebody might be
engaging in a behavior
not because of habituation, but rather
because they have some sort of deviation
from the appropriate
mapping between policies and outcomes.
And maybe there's other.
So I thought that was very interesting
how even within the same
sort of sparse
and first principles model
similar behavioral outcomes
might be observed
on like a behavioral manifolds and then
different kinds of perturbations
or evaluations
might reduce
uncertainty about what is giving rise
to those conversion behaviors.
In that case.
Okay Dean
with the ice cream truck and I.
Know I'm going to I'm going to wait
because I think that's
I think that's one of the
and the next one
are better
to take up in a12 part because I think
because if Bryan can come back
there's some good questions
I want to ask him about those
two sections
because this slide and the next one
are kind of anti dark room.
And so I want to kind of
pick his brain about what,
you know,
how we can
sort of convince people that that
that dark room problem
is for such a small subset
of the population,
that majority of
the stuff that we're talking about here
is done in in
sort of social settings
and social context and.
There's a third party
sometimes you can observe an observer
and what role that plays
in trying to figure out what's
what's going on here as we move from the
from the idea of decisioning and
and so forth. So I'll wait.
Great.
So here's part one of that
and here's part
two, looking at social learning theory
a little bit.
But let's go to the figure
and to the simulation.
This is figure
one simulation of an active inference
agent deciding
whether to eat some ice cream and
there's various
ways to go about describing it.
But one of the key pieces
that anyone can give a remark
about what is occurring
is that there's three cases
that are being compared.
There's a no desire case,
a weak desire reflected by this PFO,
and a strong desire case
where the ratio between
the two alternatives, between
wanting the ice cream
and between the ice cream state
and the no ice cream state
is a sharper distinction
in the second row.
So there's a case
in which ice cream is in the fridge,
but where the kitchen is currently dark
and so the agent doesn't know
whether the fridge
is to the left or right.
So it's like a maze set up
with three possible cases,
one where there's no preference
for observing ice cream or not a weak
or a strong preference for that.
And then
under these situations, we can ask
about
what happens in terms of the action
as well as the beliefs
and valence updates.
What else would you add about that?
Right.
Well, good point.
You know,
the point of this is just to show
why I guess makes comfortable.
I mean, so Dean mentioned that
the issue with the dark room, right?
I mean, they said I mean, as you said,
I mean, this is essentially
just a particular very similar to
to like a tmus
or atom
and just putting
and putting
a different sort
of semantics on top of it.
But they but the idea is just that
it's just
set up to show that,
you know,
even without any kind of desire, right.
Just just resolving uncertainty,
the agent will be driven
to leave a dark room or do something
to get rid of the dark room.
So you don't need a desire.
Right.
But but in fact, any realistic agent
is also going to have desires.
So.
So in the case
where there are desires,
then there's two different reasons why
no active inference agent will ever
stay in a dark room
or be motivated to stay in a dark room.
Like in all cases,
it will have a motivation to to leave.
I mean, the point is just to show, right
in some explicit simulations
that generically.
Right,
like this kind of dark room problem
is will it will just never apply
to top of inference.
Again, this dark room thing only applies
if you assume the thing
is just doing something
like predictive coding,
but then somehow
also assume that it's making decisions.
But that's not active inference
because it's not a
theory of decision making.
Awesome.
Here is some description
about the strength of the desire
could have been shown before the figure,
but we wanted to introduce
the the simulation setting
and as described there is
a desire
as well as an information seeking.
And I
believe that's
the two reasons
why the agent will escape dark room.
And there's there's other escape hatches
depending on how one
constructs their model,
potentially like a hierarchical model
might have a slightly different
explanation for why an agent does
or doesn't stay in the room.
But even just within this
single level model,
there's an information seeking
as well as a preference.
Realizing reason.
Any other comments here?
Okay, Dean.
Just a quick thing of baby.
Maybe in the island.
I'll put you in the island.
Go for it.
Yeah.
So maybe Ryan, just just a just a quick
this last last couple of census,
how our preference distributions
are set to zero.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I matched on the previous slide.
Sorry. Can you go back one.
Yeah, go for it.
Okay.
So, however, a preference distributions
are set to zero as an error.
No disaster simulation
set to the
no outcome is desired over here
and active inference agents
but nonetheless
be driven to choose behaviors
that will maximize information gain.
Okay, that all makes sense.
That's just the background.
This is the part I was curious.
Well,
while this might reasonably be
considered a motivational influence,
it is prima
facie
less plausible
that it should be considered cognitive
and may therefore
be better
seen as a type of dark, sarcastic drive
here.
The formalism
may therefore help us to recover
and potentially new onset
evoke
psychological distinction
between desire, curiosity.
These types of drives
seem to differ fundamentally.
I agree with you, but I was wondering,
if you could maybe explain why that
should be
something that we
should keep separate
the idea of desire and curiosity
I know you go into explaining it
a little more into the paper, but
why did you want to point
that out to readers?
Well, I mean,
I think there's a couple of things.
I mean I mean, one,
I think that these things
are both driving
decisions about what to do. Right.
So in some way,
they motivate
they both motivate behavior. Right.
But but at the same time
and I think this is something
that Alex Cooper
pointed out when we were writing
this, as opposed to just, you know,
so it's not just me,
but you pointed out that,
you know, there is this kind of
fairly clear difference
between the this,
you know,
curiosity or epistemic driven
sort of behavior
from the
kind of desire driven behavior
and the the
the kind of clear differences
is that
this epistemic driven motivation isn't
it isn't driven toward anything. Right.
It doesn't have a target.
It's not trying to get one thing
versus another
all it's trying to do is just
mean just become clearer
about what's out there essentially.
Right.
So the fact that it lacks a target
is really,
I think what makes the
what makes the distinction clear.
But I mean, beyond that,
I think the motivation was just to
was just to show that,
you know, like just,
you know, generically, right?
Like the belief, desire,
intention, principle doesn't really
doesn't really say anything about.
The types of types of desires.
There's nothing really explicit
interest in that.
Very, very simple
with way of describing the framework
that separates out
information seeking from from
rewards again. Right.
So, so
you could write if all you're doing
is trying to
compare active inference to,
you know, the video model
very simply stated then
then this is able to kind of nuance
a little more, right?
Like different,
different things that that
might look like
going into motivation,
all kinds of things.
But there are separate influences
on why why decisions are made
for one thing
versus another that
more kind of tied to beliefs
in a different way.
That being said,
I mean, at the same time,
I think that,
you know,
like for psychology more more broadly,
I think I think
very intuitively and naturally does
recognize the difference
between things like curiosity, right.
And things like
and things like reward driven behavior.
Right.
Those are concepts
that we have just in our natural kind
of folk psychology.
Step one
So act of inference captures
those, right? I mean, I
talk about this
just as an
example of how intuitive I think
and like natural
this sort of aspect is,
you know, and I just think of like
most of the behaviors that say
like my little dog does,
I look at if I look at what my dog does,
90% of the time,
it's way more information
seeking than it is reward seeking.
You know,
the search is out for some food
a couple of times a day,
but I take her in the car
and she's bolted left
and right to see what's out the window
and how that changes all the time,
you know, any little sound perks up
looks right.
None of those things are reward driven.
They're all just information seeking.
So, I mean, very, very
clearly, that's a big part of
what drives
us and other animals to do so.
So the point is just
just to kind of show
that active inference captures that.
And in a certain sense,
it adds some granularity to
to at least what the video model says.
But but in that case,
the video model is kind of
to a two horse grain.
And I think
normal folks, psychology
doesn't include those things already.
Great
all sorts of to be returned to Dean.
Yeah because
Brian just basically answered it all
these two images are basically doing
is separating
after
the sort of goal
directed from the curiosity which is,
you know,
the image on the right
is basically a documentary
about Franklin expedition
where
they were
going out to the event horizon,
but they never returned.
So did they have a goal?
Probably.
Was that their curiosity
being carried out?
I think we
got to be able to make sure
that we appreciate both.
So that's all I wanted.
The this makes me think like,
are you driven
to watch the sunset over the horizon
or are you driven to find out
what's at the end of the rainbow
and what's over the horizon?
And that's the sort of like infinite
open ended
curiosity drive
beyond the horizon versus the preferred
specific state
that one can desire in terms of their
observations
and reduce the divergence there.
But hope
wishful thinking will come back soon.
We're just leaving notes so that we can
have more to discuss later
because these are all like
there's such vital threads.
Ryan and Maxwell and Alex, because the
touch to our day to day experience
in a way that
few other
frameworks and even papers
within active do
so affect
and the role of affect and precision
and curiosity.
These are all just like
terms that touch humans.
One thing that I you know,
that I think is probably worth
just touching on a minute ago
something maybe
you guys would
want to talk about in the future.
You know, maybe when I'm not around
and the other
any other sections, but sure.
But you know,
so there is a probably a distinction
that's worth
keeping in mind between curiosity
and and goal directed information.
I think some of the examples
you guys have mentioned
have been more kind of
along the lines of one versus the other.
So I think it might be good
to just
just keep that distinction clear
that, you know,
and and vanilla active inference
is really something more
just kind of like curiosity,
just kind of like independently driven,
this kind of
look where you're going
to gain the most information.
Whereas, you know,
the construct of directed exploration
and reinforcement learning and,
and what also, you know, often
something that can emerge,
I think, a little more
clearly in like
sophisticated active inference
is, you know, is information
seeking specifically
or in the service of knowing
how to get your whole
the curiosity aversion
that we're showing here.
It has the effect of helping the agent
get what it wants.
But but the drive to seek out
information isn't actually itself
due to the fact that the agent thinks
it will help it get in school.
It's just going to seek
the information independent.
Whereas whereas in in other yeah.
Like sophisticated inference
they the agent is actually
doing something more like
I'm going to look over here
because I think looking over here
is actually going to help me
get to what I want better. Right.
So this is kind of strategic
information seeking
and that's
that's a little different
than just like intrinsic curiosity.
So it's just something to keep clear.
That's quite interesting.
It kind of ties the brain back.
But let's explore that later
here.
We have a nice, clean
representation
of the summary of the main arguments
there.
Proposed solution
is somewhat deflationary
in the sense
that it
simply argues
that the functional role of desire,
not the experience of desire,
is straightforward, straightforwardly,
present in the formalism
and then in more detail.
They argue that
and they provide four points,
which it'll be great
to go over with with the authors
based on those considerations,
the apparent problem
posed by purely dark, sarcastic
looking constructs
is simply not a problem.
There are beliefs and desires
in the active inference framework.
Perhaps we could have
explored this more with the formalism,
so we'll bring it up to talking about S,
but I won't go into it now.
We'll return to the letters later
and then the appendix is
very informative
there's a description of all the states
and the factors
that are used in the simulation
and in the model stream.
One, which is, by the way, Ryan, it's
our most popular
series was Model Stream one.
It was it was a is a fan favorite, but
it's some
similar concepts and MATLAB script.
So the appendix describes how the Fig.
one results were generated
and maybe we'll see
if anybody can run that and execute it.
We can play with a few different things
and take some of these
qualitative linguistics
and even mutate the simulation
a little bit.
See where that takes us.
We'll close out
with our usual closing slide.
So who would like to take the first
last word?
Yes, Dean, then young Ryan.
First of all, thanks for shepherding us
these three cats, this paper,
because there's an awful lot of stuff
to try to cover in a
pretty short period of time.
And it was and it's easy,
I think, to
sort of go,
I don't want to say
tangentially,
but go deeper into some of the
parts of the paper, because
for me, it was one of those
ones where I would go back
and have to reflect on something
after I read a section
and then try to
fit it into the larger picture.
There was Ryan.
I think the paper
did a very good of sort
of ordering through
what you were trying to say
in terms
of the reassurance
of how the the quantitative
and the
and the modeling, the psychosocial
could be seen as working
with each other,
as opposed to though
this doesn't answer
what this other thing questions,
but it does
this is
this was a paper that for me,
I won't speak for the others,
but I had to read the section
and then
try to
plug it back into the overall narrative
that was being told.
And again,
I think part of that is because
that the translation from the stuff
that's typically
seen as
the quantitative part
is hard to move into.
The qualitative part,
I think that's that's a challenge
for anybody
that tries to move back
and forth between those two things. But
yeah, I mean, in terms of,
in terms of making a case and,
and providing what I think
people need to sort of
see the two in the same light.
Thank you.
Appreciate it.
Sure. I'm in happy.
Happy if it's helpful.
Okay.
Yeah, I think in
I guess there are two points
that I like to touch on.
Firstly,
I think I thought it was very helpful to
map this for these concepts
that everyone, even though everyone
I guess that's the nature of psychology
that everyone have a slightly,
slightly different probably distribution
of what they these terms actually mean.
But I think it's in just learning
about active inference, it's helpful
to link
the math and mathematical formulation
and even just
the active inference ontology,
which itself can be very cumbersome
at times
to these very intuitive concepts and.
I think as we get
we're starting to explore modeling
within the accident flap as well.
I think it's
it will be really helpful to use
this asymmetric prism between
active inference and folk psychology
to explain
the behavior of agents
within these models
and not beyond in our group problem.
And there is some unexpected behavior
of an agent we can directly look at.
Okay, how how did
this tensor
change its values and?
Describe it with this
looks like a psychological ontology.
So I think personally that's
the most exciting thing about this
paper coming.
Yeah.
Here I mean, if,
I mean if that's
the kind of thing that you're interested
in, then I mean, that's
kind of the whole
it's kind of all motivation
of inferences
like computational psychiatry, right?
Which is like the area that I work on.
You you take, for instance,
clinical populations
where people may behave in unexpected
or ways
or ways that don't necessarily seem
like they're all that adaptive. Right?
And you can just fit these models
to their behavior
and you can figure out, okay, well,
what is making their behavior
abnormal, right?
Is it
is it
something about an overly precise
preference distribution or is
it something about,
you know,
the belief
that states states transition to
to into volatile or uncertain way
or things like that.
So, I mean, it is the yeah,
I mean, the kind of
you know,
the major point is
you can use these models
in empirical studies
to figure out what the mechanisms are
that are leading to healthy
and unhealthy behavior
and
that can
give you
kind of guiding information toward
better treatments or,
you know,
trying to measure these things
in a more quantitative
way, things like that.
And and the
you know,
and just as I said,
I mean, this is all using
using tasks that, you know, that involve
some kind of goal, right?
Like seeking
some kind of reward or official approval
or whatever it is that humans seek out.
You could do that, right?
Unless you have
a straightforward way to map
the formalism,
each element of the formalism to,
you know, the reason
that we think people
behave in the way that they do.
Right. So, so on.
So I guess I'm just saying this,
if that's an interest of yours,
then I would think that you would.
You're probably a fan of a lot of that.
A lot of the computational
psychiatry literature more broadly,
both of the active inference part,
which is a lot of what my lab does, but
but also just the broader
computational psychiatry community
that uses reinforcement
learning and replication models
and all the other programs
and all the other classics
that are out there.
Cool.
And it opens it up, what
organizations want and what the cells
want and all these other
trans positions.
Well, Ryan, really appreciate
that last minute
belief or desire,
combination thereof to join us.
Certainly help
resolve our uncertainty a lot
And it's a great conversation.
In the coming two weeks,
we're going to be
with hopefully some more authors
and more lab participants and just
I'm looking forward
to taking some notes.
Thank you.
See you all soon.
By.